et en direct sur public sénat
effectivement la séance se poursuit ce
soir on va très vite écouter esther
benbassa et ceci le cul kerman les
sénatrices à la fois écologistes et
communistes qui présente en ce moment
même leurs amendements pour ouvrir la
pma aux couples de femmes
on les écoute cette possibilité doit
être ouverte si les enfants ont été
conçus à l'étranger même si l'on espère
et revendique que la pema soit
rapidement ouverte aux couples de femmes
en france puisqu'il n'y a plus de 8000
femmes qui ont recours à la pma à
l'étranger merci à vis de la commission
commissaire donner des avis défavorables
pour des raisons différentes
d'abord aux amendements de ce dernier
chez retailleau parce qu'en fait ils ont
déjà satisfait pma bon ce qu'ils disent
ce qu'ils affirmé yahia dans la loi pas
dans celle là dans la loi sur les pma et
avis défavorable également aux
amendements de madame benbassa évident
qu kerman même si la commission a eu un
débat là-dessus si elle comprend bien
l'intérêt des amendements présentés par
mesdames bataille que kmad pour lancer
le débat
c'est vrai que la pma n'est pas dans le
périmètre de ce texte après sept heures
de discussions qui ont eu lieu à la
famille nationale notamment votre
commission des lois a décidé de garder
le périmètre du texte tel que le
présenter le projet de loi est donc à
reporter ses amendements pour l'instant
poser question de pure forme
par rapport au projet de loi qu'elle qui
se présentent à vis du gouvernement
madame la ministre
une attention particulière pour la
combativité de ses sénatrice donc
benbassa et kerman avis défavorable
venir - mais vous savez parfaitement que
nous sommes hors périmètre du texte
merci monsieur godefroy
oui monsieur le président ce sera très
rapide parce qu'effectivement j'ai
souscrit aux propos de monsieur le
rapporteur et madame la ministre
hors périmètre simplement mes chers
collègues je voudrais vous rappeler que
lors de la révision des lois bioéthiques
en première lecture
j'avais eu l'honneur de défendre un
amendement du groupe socialiste qui
avait été adoptée je vais rappeler quel
était cet amendement cet amendement
visait à permettre l'assistance médicale
à la procréation vie dure à mp moi je
préfère pour des raisons qu'ils soient
médicale ou sociale ou sociétale on
avait dit et à l'époque en première
lecture des lois bioéthiques ce qu'était
la démo sans rappeler j'avais reçu le
soutien actif du rapporteur de l'époque
monsieur alain milon et ce est cet
amendement a été voté par notre
assemblée
cet amendement être répondre il a été
voté par l'autre assemblée
ensuite en deuxième lecture ont
apparemment il ya eu quelques
instructions qui ont été données ceux
qui étaient là s'en souvienne je suppose
il n'empêche que notre assemblée en a
débattu et dans les lois bioéthique
avait voté en première lecture à une
très large majorité
je rappelle simplement que ceux qui
voudraient envoyer le débat aux lois
bioéthiques
à l'époque on nous avait dit les lois
bioéthiques maintenant on sait tous on
en discute plus il avait fallu un long
combat pour qu'on en rediscute b la
discussion est reportée à danser temps
et donc je pense qu'il faudra pas
attendre sept ans pour rediscuter de la
mp c'est ce que je voulais simplement
rappelé tu vous remercie monsieur le
président m'avait accordé la parole
quelques instants
monsieur alain richard
monsieur le président je respecte tout à
fait l'inspiration de certains de nos
collègues à ouvrir ce débat mais la
façon dont ils étaient ouverts me
surprend quand madame benbassa dit que
s'il ne s'agit pas d'une question
éthique
je ne comprends pas son argument c'est
une question éthique par excellence très
bien je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement de monsieur darniche
l'amendement 233 rectifier ce qui sont
pour les de la main merci ceux qui sont
contre abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté l'amendement numéro sort de
madame benbassa ceux qui sont pour oui
je vais retirer l'amendement sans lui
mais je compte sur la la réflexion sur
la famille et les lois qui vont suivre
pour qu'on prenne en considération cet
aspect de la question qui est aussi très
importante et retiré un amendement 253
il est retiré un amendement 258 rectifié
de monsieur retailleau ceux qui sont
pour ce qu'ils sont contre abstentions
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 99 de madame benbassa même
sort très bien il est retiré ainsi que
l'amant de nantes 252 de madame kuperman
je passe à l'amendement 122 rectifié qui
a été présentée par monsieur retailleau
quel est l'avis de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement même avis
merci je vais donc le mettre aux voix ce
qui sont pour ceux qui sont contre
abstentions un amendement n'est pas
adopté j'en viens à 5 amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
amendement 123 rectifié de monsieur
retailleau c'est le président madame
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues
il s'agit de modifier le code 2
la santé publique parce qu'on a bien vu
dans l'ensemble de nos débats que il y
un risque des techniques médicales de
procréation et le risque débouchera sur
le problème de l'accès aux origines par
cet amendement solennellement pour
pointer cette faille
eh bien nous souhaitons institué le
principe de la levée de l'anonymat du
donneur de gamètes afin de prendre en
compte l'intérêt des enfants qui seront
soucier d'avoir accès à leurs origines
amendement 165 qu'identique euractiv à
165 rectifié de monsieur b coup cet
amendement je considère il vient d'être
défendu par bruno retailleau
merci amendements identiques également
167 rectifié de monsieur le
merci amendement 203 de monsieur v ça va
être la même position
non disons simplement que c'est un
problème qu'il faudra résoudre parce que
j'ai reçu des enfants issus de gamètes
et qui m'ont dit on voudrait quand même
pour un seul nombre de raisons avoir
accès à un certain nombre d'éléments
d'amendements 250 septembre quel est
l'avis de la commission sur ces
amendements identiques
maintenant il est hostile je rappelle à
mes collègues d'ailleurs est un vrai
problème oui conesa plage la commission
et aux kills pardon je rappelle à mes
collègues que nous avons eu un débat ici
assez long cette question lors de la
révision des lois bioéthiques je me
souviens bien
un certain nombre d'entre nous étions
favorables à la levée de l'anonymat
finalement ça n'a pas été adopté vous
connaissez les objections qui valent ce
qu'elles valent les objections c'est que
sur lève l'anonymat il n'y aura plus de
donneurs voilà alors pour l'instant
la commission y est défavorable en plus
c'est pas le débat dans ce texte au nom
du gouvernement sujet majeur complexe
également aimé avis défavorable ce n'est
pas le débat de ce texte très bien je
soumets ou voit ces amendements ceux qui
sont pour la main ceux qui sont contre
abstention ces amendements ne sont pas
adoptées j'en viens à l'amendement 114
rectifié de monsieur retailleau monsieur
le président c'est un amendement qui
repose le principe de précaution pour
les sujets dont nous débattons notamment
c'est un principe d'ailleurs qui est
valable sur tous les sujets je vous
rappelle qu'il est à émerger pour la
première fois en 1992 c'était le
principe 15 de la déclaration de rio la
loi barnier en 1995 l'avait repris à son
compte la vers formulée dans un texte
législatif et ensuite l'ensemble de nos
débats qui avaient conduit à la révision
constitutionnelle et à la charte de
l'environnement avait si j'ose dire
consacré ce principe d'un point de vue
constitutionnel
je loue souhaitons rappeler avec le
groupe ump solennellement que ce
principe ne saurait si j'ose dire faire
l'objet du zoo différents suivant qu'il
s'agisse de sujets ou d'un autre les
sujets dont nous traitons sont du sujet
extrêmement grave
nous savons qu'il n'y a pas de consensus
scientifique sur les conséquences sur
les enfants et donc nous souhaitons
réaffirmer avec force que ce principe de
précaution doit s'appliquer pour tous
les sujets y compris les plus graves
bien entendu puis à vis de la commission
défavorable cet amendement est sans
objet
car lorsque le juge prenantes adoption
il la prononce dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant c'est ce qui a été dit tout au
long des auditions
donc ça ne fait aucun doute donc
défavorable à l'amendement du
gouvernement pardon un vide de la même
l'article 353 dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
nous n'arrêtons pas de le marteler avis
défavorable
je vais mettre aux voix monsieur longuet
vous avez la parole oui naturellement
dans l'intérêt de l'enfant encore
faut-il savoir qui est cet enfant
qu'elle sait quel est son héritage
génétique est la question que pose bruno
retailleau et parfaitement perm
pertinentes et d'ailleurs est légitime
le les amendements précédent que vous
avez repoussé sur le droit de l'enfant à
connaître ses origines vous avez avoir
des enfants qui n'auront pas la faculté
que la science ouvre désormais d'acceder
à la médecine génétique c'est-à-dire
celles qui
se fonde sur la connaissance des
antécédents génétiques de cet enfant
alors dans l'intérêt de l'enfant le juge
n'en a qu'une appréciation sociale il y
a un volet médical génétique c'est pas
ma spécialité mais c'est une observation
de bon sens et je trouve surprenant que
vous les quartiers aussi facilement mais
nous le retrouverons dans le débat sur
la famille bien je mets aux voileux 114
rectifier ce qui sont pour ceux qui sont
contre abstention l'amendement n'est pas
adopté un amendement 115 rectifié de
monsieur otayo monsieur le président
mesdames les ministres mesdames
messieurs chers collègues
c'est une question qui est extrêmement
délicate puisque si ce texte devient loi
l'adoption pour les couples de même sexe
sera bien entendu dans la loi sera
autorisée et par cet amendement ce que
nous souhaitons faire c'est permettre
aux parents par une disposition
testamentaire de faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent indiquer leur adoption
en tout cas l'adoption si jamais il
venait à décéder pour qu'ils puissent
définir les conditions dans lesquelles
ils souhaiteraient que leur enfant soit
adopté c'est extrêmement important
ça peut être de rares cas où des cas
limites mais je pense que on doit
pouvoir le prévoir dans la loi à partir
du moment où ces conditions d'adoption
vont dès lors radicalement changé la vie
de la commission avis défavorable avec
les parents des faits de la loi c'est
que c'est le conseil de famille sous
l'autorité du juge qui décide si
l'enfant peut être adoptées ou pas et
par qui donc avis défavorable à vis du
gouvernement
c'est un sujet qui peut faire l'objet de
la préparation du texte sur la famille
parce que c'est une disposition qui a
été d'ailleurs abordé à l'assemblée
nationale donc elle n'est pas nulle et
non avenue mais elle n'est pas
pertinente sur ce texte là pour ces
raisons avis défavorable
merci je vais le mettre aux voix ceux
qui sont favorables lève la main ceux
qui sont contre abstentions il n'est pas
adopté j'en viens à cinq amendements
identiques amendements sans cesse
rectifié de monsieur retailleau
je vais les soutenir mais très vite
parce que le 116 rectifier le 117
rectifier le 118 rectifié parle de
l'intérêt des enfants et je ne vois pas
pourquoi ils ont été classés à ce moment
là alors que nous en avons parlé
beaucoup plus haut lorsque nous avons si
j'ose dire attaqué l'article additionnel
par conséquent je considère que je les
ai déjà défendu il s'agit de réaffirmer
l'intérieur supérette d'enfants
notamment d'avoir un père et une mère et
notamment avec à l'appui tous les textes
internationaux que j'ai déjà cité
maintes fois merci le 153 rectifié
madame bruguières
merci le 160 rectifié monsieur bécaud la
même chose monsieur président était je
vous remercie de 198 me surveille même
chose
nous répétons et nous sommes nombreux à
répéter qu'il faut tenir compte de la
place de l'enfant alors ce sera
peut-être dans la feu dans le projet de
loi sur la famille mais cela est l'objet
principal de nos débats et
malheureusement durant le débat on n'y a
pas beaucoup parlé
merci de 223 tombe je vais mettre on
voit ces amendements identiques ceux qui
sont pour les bleus que pardon pardon
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur je vous
laisse la parole bien volontiers à vis
de la commission et ensuite je
demanderais aussi du gouvernement la
commission a donné des avis défavorables
car cet amendement font primer de
biologique dans les lois sur l'adoption
c'est contraire à tous nos principes
avis défavorable à vis du gouvernement
même avis pour les mêmes raisons je vais
mettre ces amendements aux voix ce qui
sont pour l'esv la main ceux qui sont
contre abstentions ces amendements ne
sont pas adoptées j'en viens à cinq
amendements identiques de 117 déjà
défendue par monsieur retailleau 105 454
madame rigueur nous sommes d'accord 161
monsieur bécaud même même sort 199 me
surveille également et donc 225
bon ben je vais mettre aux voix assez
abandonnant ceux qui sont pour l avis de
la commission pardonnez moi c'est la
deuxième troisième fois je me passe de
l'avis de la commission
l'avis de la commission ces boucles la
colline non mais les commissaires est
défavorable pourquoi parce que l'intérêt
de l'enfant
l'intérêt de l'enfant prime eux
dormaient déjà dans le droit positif et
qu'il est inutile de mettre toute autre
considération avait du gouvernement même
défaut superfétatoire donc même avis
défavorable bien je vais donc les mettre
aux voix ce qu'ils sont pour ceux qui
sont contre abstention merci ils ne sont
pas adoptées je viens à 15 amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune le 127 de madame benbassa
l'argument a été maintes fois entendu ce
le mariage serait gage de stabilité pour
le couple et donc de sécurité affective
et légal pour l'enfant quand on sait
qu'à paris un mariage sur deux se
termine par un divorce
cet argument bien sûr ne tiennent pas en
2010 plus de deux cent cinq mille pacs
ont été conclus
d'autre part à l'époque des débats sur
le pacs l'adoption en avait été exclu
car elle aurait été rouverte aux couples
de personnes de même sexe ce droit étant
voué à l'issue de nos débats être ouvert
à tous les couples mariés
cette interdiction pour les couples
pacsés n'a plus lieu d'être
pour toutes ces raisons nous proposons
d'ouvrir le droit à l'adoption aux
couples pacsés
si le mandement 205 rectifié 215
rectifié bis tombe amendement 23
rectifié bis de monsieur jodar
dans madame les ministres si vous voulez
bien
cet amendement 23 bis se rectifier plus
le 24 le 25 le 26 et le 27 rectifier eh
bien ce sont les amendements que je vais
être amené à retirer pour une raison
très simple ce qu'ils défendent ce que
l'on appelait en commission le point de
vue adam et eve
et bien ne cédez pas c'est maintenant
contenu ce que nous avons adoptée mais
je regrette que nous ayons pas suivi que
vous n'ayez pas suivi ce que nous avions
proposé à l'époque très bien ces
amendements sont retirés j'en viens à
l'amendement 232 rectifié de monsieur
dernier
le président mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à limiter les cas
d'adoption des couples mariés aux seuls
couples hétérosexuels car tout enfant a
droit un père et une mère en particulier
s'il a subi la perte de ses parents
merci amendement 118 de rectifier de
monsieur retailleau a été défendu le 155
rectifier
madame bruguières a été défendu
également 160 de rectifier monsieur
bécaud également 200 mesures vais
également
je vais donc demander l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
alors monsieur gillard a dit la raison
pour laquelle il retire être
l'amendement tous les autres sont
semblables fait les amendements qu'ils
réservent l'adoption pour les couples
hétérosexuels
ça a été voté quand donc on est contre
madame benbassa d'amendements un peu
différent on n'amène pas ça on a dit ici
qu on évoquerait pas la question du pacs
même si monsieur millon étaient d'accord
avec vous il serait peut-être logique
devrait après je pense qu'il serait
logique d'ouvrir la possibilité
d'adoption aux couples pacsés
ce n'est pas dans le périmètre de ce
texte je vous demande donc de retirer
votre amendement très bien l'avis du
gouvernement l'avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre
un avis défavorable j'essaie juste de
comprendre
non mais je pense que monsieur darniche
funérailles non parce que il nous a dit
que un enfant
très bien l'avis du gouvernement ayant
été donnée je vais mettre aux voix
oui oui pardon monsieur raffarin je vous
en prie vous avez juste à mon seul
président mais elle garde des sceaux
mais puisqu'on est dans une ambiance un
peu détendus on est quand même là sur un
sujet extrêmement grave et je veux
vraiment dire à tous ceux qui nous
regardent que ce débat-là et le débat
essentiel
alors on revient pas sur le débat parce
qu'on la tranchée mais il faudrait pas
croire qu'en fin de parcours comme ça on
lâche près ce sont nos convictions de
fond un enfant a droit à un papa et une
maman c'est le coeur même de cet
amendement c'est fondamental mais nous
en avons déjà beaucoup débattu très bien
je vous remercie monsieur premier
ministre voilà la sagesse de jean pierre
raffarin ancien premier ministre qui
reconnaît qu'effectivement ils ont déjà
beaucoup débattu sur ce texte david
assouline sénateur et porte parole du
parti socialiste est avec nous bonsoir
effectivement huit jours de débats sur
ce projet de loi c'est déjà beaucoup
oui c'est beaucoup mais c'était mais
c'était nécessaire
je je suis partagé parce que je
comprends bien que ceux qui combattent
ce texte veulent faire durer parce c'est
pas seulement pour enrichir les débats
il ya ce que les opposants texte et à
ceux aussi qui ont envie de se faire une
opinion de comprendre quelles peuvent
être les régions telles mesures
justement c'est pour cela que je voulais
que je veux je faisais cette parenthèse
c'est que il ya des arguments qui ont
été répétés de façon identique pendant
des heures et des fois justement pour
ceux qui nous regardent
c'est une image qui peuvent avoir du
parlement ils savent qu'il ya beaucoup
de textes notamment du gouvernement de
problèmes dans le pays qu'il faut qu'on
traite donc jeu il faut prendre le temps
il ya eu des moments un peu dur
d'obstruction caractérisé
oui on peut dire que ce soit mais quand
même pas représentative de tout ce qu'on
a vécu ces derniers jours l'ambiance
était plus peut-être pas tendu mais en
tout cas il y avait une vraie bataille
d'opinion dans l'hémicycle donc
c'est normal que ceux qui s'opposent pas
tellement pour argumenter comme vous
l'avez dit fasse durer c'est une façon
de montrer à leurs partisans à
l'extérieur que il son opiniâtre qu'il
se batte et c'est ça c'est de la posture
sur les débats je pense qu'on a été bien
au fond des choses je trouve dommage on
l'a encore vu là y compris par le rappel
de monsieur raffarin qu' il est porté
beaucoup d'heures de débat sur un débat
qu'on aura lieu dans un autre texte
toussaint la famille à la pma la gp en
général à la famille qui sont des sujets
à traiter à part
ils veulent faire le lien en disant qu
automatiquement sans j'en aurais je ne
crois pas on est sûr le code civil il
n'ya rien automatique qui ont engendré
par cette loi mais en tous les cas
globalement elle est inscrite à l'ordre
du jour elle n'est pas encore née sept
mois sur la famille même si elle a été
promise par le gouvernement
il y aura une loi sur la famille parce
que ils compris dans le débat sur
l'adoption il ya beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui sans le mariage homosexuel
qui sont insatisfaisantes donc c'est
normal que avec tes nouveaux problèmes
que pose la société dont son évolution
la composition des familles qui a
beaucoup bougé vous le savez est bien
qu'on revienne régulièrement au
parlement pour parler de cela
en tous les cas globalement voilà on
sent que c'est la fin c'est dur quand on
a été vraiment présent à 1
à toutes les sessions parce que ça se
condamnent tous les soirs et
effectivement c'est dur mais bon le
débat en valait le coup c'était
intéressant si les opposants au texte ne
désarme pas la manif pour tous
manifestent ce soir encore devant les
grilles du sénat il ya une autre date de
manifestation qui a été annoncé à la fin
du mois de mai donc la bataille autour
de ce projet de loi est loin d'être
finie il y aura une seconde lecture dans
les deux chambres
oui en tant que c'est pas fini c'est pas
fini je veux juste dire tout de même pas
ce que vous évoquez ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur que si parfois s'était fait
très ici je n'ai pas accepté je l' ai
d'ailleurs dit dans un rappel au
règlement qu'il y ait un peu double jeu
on ne peut pas à l'extérieur chauffée à
blanc par fois en dix ans les mensonges
ceux qui manifestent on voit qu'il ya
des dérapages et quand il ya des
dérapages faut tout de suite les
condamnés saccage d'une rassemblement
associatif ce qui se marrent faller et
souvent même de mouvements radicaux à
l'extrémité 1 2 oui mais il faut les
dépenses et donc il faut tout simplement
énoncé sur les deux bancs de l'assemblée
de l'hémicycle n'est pas entendu de
dénonciation claire et nette de ce
qu'ils ont fait ces actes il ya eu des
généralités
je ne les ai pas entendus pour ça que je
les demande est d'ailleurs et je le dis
parce que y compris la dernière
manifestation bien entendu qu'elle avait
un caractère pacifique mais le fais
jusqu'à quatre jours avant d'avoir
appelé à manifester sur les
champs-elysées a poussé compris les gens
qui ne savaient pas à vouloir y aller à
tout prix a concédé une injustice de
paix y aller alors ça fait rêver la
provocation de la part des organisateurs
la manifestation
j avais une irresponsabilité et puis
après il ya des provocateurs qui sur la
base des responsabilités bien on libre
court et quand dans la manifestation
on entendait en boucle sur les chaînes
d'info que ou tirent sur des enfants ou
gaz des enfants des expressions aussi
fort dans la bouche de monsieur wauquiez
ou de monsieur guaino eh bien je ne
pense pas que ça poussait dans ce moment
de tension à faire baisser la tension au
contraire ça là ça
à croix c'est les risques dont ce que je
veux dire c'est que le débat doit
continuer la navette va continuer si
nous avions d'ailleurs voulu qu'il n'y
ait pas de navette
ils l'ont fait dans le passé quand ils
étaient majoritaires au sénat
ils auraient voté conforme on n'a pas
voté conforme ça va repartir
mais attention vigilance il ne faut pas
que le droit de manifester se transforme
en laisser aller à n'importe quoi j'ai
deux habitants de mon arrondissement un
couple homosexuel qui s'embrasser dans
la rue
le week-end dernier ils avaient tabassé
très violemment et ça laisse libre cours
à des choses et je les dis aussi moi
quand on me met les tensions et les
temps d'attenté sur phases finales ils
ne sont pas finir à la deuxième lecture
donc ça va durer jusqu'à cet été
toujours est il que quand le prof le
pays traverse autant de problèmes
sociaux est ce qu'il est si utile de
passer autant de temps sur des réformes
sociétales sks que l'urgence est là non
mais cc c'est fort de café de nous faire
ce reproche c'est pas nous qui faisons
durer et si ça dure c'est parce qu'ils
ont voulu un débat qui dure il
d'opposition bain bien sûr c'est
souvenez vous la gauche n'était pas très
nombreuse toujours dans l'hémicycle
aussi ici au sénat qui est une
multiplication des scrutins publics là
aussi on a perdu 8 en jeu c'est pas
tellement ça qui a fait perdre du temps
regardez bien c'est quand on s'inscrit à
35 40 pour intervenir sur article après
l'avoir fait sur le débat général après
le faire sur un ensemble d'amendements
au sénat on n'a pas besoin de déposer
mille amendements pour faire durer parce
qu'à pas tant contre un chacun peut
parler et donc on peut jouer à ça mais
est-ce que ce que je veux dire par
rapport à la licence à la question 1 à
l'urgence il y à un texte qui est arrivé
ils ont voulu faire deux semaines à
l'assemblée ici ils ont fait durer dix
jours ils ont tout de suite dit
attention il va l'empêcher le débat et
cetera
ils vont faire l'urgence on n'a pas
déclaré l'urgence pour pas qui est cet
argument on sait très bien comment on
peut aller très vite en brutalisant les
débats et nous aurait dénoncé en disant
il brutalise le débat donc on laisse les
choses se faire normalement le rôle du
parlement il ya des manifs
les stations tout cela est respecté mais
qu'on vienne pas nous reprocher à nous
de ne pas nous occuper du reste on ne
fait que ça ait eu pour l'instant us
beaucoup de leur énergie que là dessus
vous les avez vus sur les la loi
bancaire
avoir autant de de punch sur le budget
etc et on verra la semaine prochaine
effectivement avec le prochain texte
merci julien david assouline tenue en
direct ce soir on va repartir dans
l'hémicycle pour suivre la suite de ces
débats autour de ce projet de loi avec
la fin les l'examen des amendements et
des derniers articles sur ce texte
delphine on vous retrouve en tribune de
presse
ça va assez vite ce soir ça avance assez
vite ah oui perrine 1 c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire le rythme s'est
vraiment accéléré
même jean-pierre bel on sent qu'il a
envie d'aller vite la preuve c'est
qu'ils en oublient eux mêmes parfois de
demander l'avis de la commission ou
encore l'avis du gouvernement en tous
les cas et bien les amendements
importants 1 qui avait été déposé par
ccq germann ou encore aux esther
benbassa pourrait bien autoriser la pma
pour les couples de femmes
ces amendements ont été retirés il
s'agissait pour les sénatrices de lancer
le débat sur la question le gouvernement
a répondu eh bien que cette question
fera l'objet d'un futur projet loi un
projet de loi sur la famille
enfin la droite qui avait également
tenté de demander la levée de l'anonymat
pour les donneurs de gamètes et bien à
vue ces amendements refusés à la fois
par le gouvernement
toujours la même réponse eh bien on
n'est pas ici dans le périmètre de la
loi alors on va retourner dans
l'hémicycle où vous l'avez dit eh bien
allez débat s'accélère en talent pour
permettre l'intervention d'un tiers
ces propositions visent à renforcer le
maintien des liens affectifs tissés
entre l'enfant et un tiers de
circonstances particulières telles que
le décès et la soif et la séparation la
bande 979 vise donc à compléter le
régime des actes usuels de l'autorité
parentale pour lesquels le code civil
prévoit déjà une présomption d'accord
des parents en consacrant la possibilité
offerte à chacun des parents de déléguer
une autorisation aux beaux-parents
d'accomplir ses actes c'est donc une
ouverture tout à fait importante
pour que le parent seul ne soit pas
isolée vis-à-vis de l'enfant et
l'amendement 104 de monsieur bah merci
monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui a été rédigée dans le
même esprit que les amendements que
viennent défendre notre collègue
detraigne si vous le permettez je dirai
un mot également du 102 2 102 104 se
démarque de jurisprudence d'ailleurs de
la cour de cassation et vise à les fixer
dans nos textes législatifs permettant
pour l'un que la une autorisation par
les titulaires de l'autorité parentale
soit donnée aux tiers résidant avec l'un
des deux parents d'accomplir des actes
usuels au nom de l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant et pour l'autre que également
on puisse obtenir du juge qu'il autorise
un tiers accomplira sa trompe de d'actes
dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
merci donc monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission sur le
31 rectifié 1179 rectifié terre le
centquatre et on pourrait joindre le 102
que monsieur bah vient de présenter
oui c'est trois ou quatre amendements
les trois premiers sont directement
semblables il aborde un problème réel et
ils tendent à simplifier la vie courante
toutefois ils n'offrent pas de garanties
juridiques requises en effet rédigé
comme ils sont on voit de quelle
instrumentalisation une telle
disposition pourrait faire l'objet en
cas de séparation conflictuelle des
parents
donc moi je crois que la réflexion doit
être poursuivi alors là ça sera moins
conflictuelle que pour la pma dans le
cas d'une loi sur la famille qui
définira le statut du beau parent avait
toutes les garanties juridiques
donc moi j'étais défavorable par contre
la commission afghane avis favorable à
ces amendements
quand autre 104 102 de monsieur bah il y
a satisfait par le droit positif vous
chers collègues
un vis du gouvernement oui nous émettons
un avis défavorable le même si les
questions que vous posez sur la le
statut du beau parent sont des questions
importantes mais qui s'adresse
indifféremment aux familles
hétérosexuelles comme aux familles
homosexuelles donc qui ne rentrent pas
spécifiquement dans le cadre de cette
loi mais qui effectivement sous ses
aspects les plus divers et complexes
sera étudiée dans le cadre de la
prochaine loi famille avis défavorable
him huy pardonnez moi c'est une question
que je connais un petit peu pour l'avoir
pratiqué cette question d'autorité de
délégation d'autorité parentale dépasse
largement la question des beaux parents
et ses tares et cetera et quand
l'adoption internationale se fait elle
peut commencer par une délégation
d'autorité parentale pendant quelques
années avant d'accéder à l'adoption
plénière bien et à partir du moment où
cette question de délégation d'autorité
parentale qui est délégué un 10000 20000
km de là parfois et bien rédigé par le
juge pour enfants il n'y a aucun
problème aucun problème et par
conséquent j'appelle l'attention de mes
collègues sur le fait que certes il ya
la question les beaux parents quand on
habite à un kilomètre de les uns des
autres qui que c'était extra qu'il peut
y avoir conflit mais plus généralement
il faudra bien réfléchir dans le cadre
effectivement sur dans le cadre la loi
sur la famille sur cette question
d'autorité parentale qui est une
question très importante mais qui est
déjà pas mal organisés et surtout ne
détruisons pas ce qui marche assez bien
merci monsieur le sénateur
je mets au voir les amendements 31
rectifié bis et 579 rectifier taire ceux
qui sont pour l'esv la main merci ceux
qui sont contre abstentions ils ne sont
pas adoptées même vote pour le
centquatre même voix pour le 102 merci
je passe à présent à trois amendements
en discussion commune l'amendement 32
rectifié bis de monsieur g d'are on a
cet amendement le cherchons à faire en
sorte que les parents ou l'un des deux
ne et le pouvoir de confier des pierres
le soin de réaliser de façon
occasionnelle ou temporaire certains
actes concernant l'enfant
ce mandat pourrait concerner des actes
usuels et s'il ya accord des deux
parents des actes graves
il se ferait par simple convention et
prendrait fin par la volonté du mandant
ou du mandataire merci 280 rectifié
terre monsieur détraigne et les défendu
le 96 rectifier
madame bruguières où monsieur retailleau
il est défendu
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis est défavorable encore fois c'est
un problème très important et très grave
mais franchement monsieur gérard c'est
une novation extraordinaire que vous
introduisez dans ce texte puisque vous
dites et ceux qui connaissent bien la
législation sur l'autorité parentale
seront particulièrement sensibles
le dispositif est inédit puisqu'il crée
un mandat d'autorité parentale
ponctuelles donnée par des parents à un
tiers y compris pour accomplir des actes
graves comme le passage d'une frontière
où des actes chirurgicaux sans garantie
est en contradiction avec l'article 365
du code civil qui dit qu'aucune
renonciation aucune cession portant sur
l'autorité parentale ne peut avoir
d'effet si ce n'est en vertu d'un
jugement
donc la commission moi j'utilise est
favorable la commission est d'avis a
émis un avis favorable
pour les grecs question de présence mais
je pense qu'il faut reposer que les
amendements avis favorable de la
commission très bien madame la garde des
sceaux madame la ministre à vis du
gouvernement
oui c'est cette question de la
délégation de l'autorité parentale et
des conditions de son exercice c'est
effectivement des questions importantes
mais je reviens sur ce que j'ai dit
antérieurement
cela concerne indifféremment les couples
quel qu'il soit où les situations
familiales des plus variés et cela
nécessite d'être approfondis travailler
dans le cadre d'une autre loi qui sera
la loi famille et non pas dans le cadre
de cette loi spécifique
donc avis défavorable merci monsieur
jean claude lenoir vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre je soutiens tout à fait
l'amendement de mon collègue gélard nous
nous retrouvons souvent dans des
collectivités locales en tant que maire
présidente que des communes avec des
problèmes liés au fait que nous ne
savons pas exactement quelle est la
personne qui peut avoir autorité sur une
décision à prendre notamment en cas
d'hospitalisation
imaginez une colonie de vacances un
centre aéré des activités périscolaires
il ya des situations extrêmement
complexe dans certains cas je comprends
qu'il ne puisse pas y avoir de réponse
au moment où je parle
mais si on nous dit une loi sur la
famille on ne sait pas comment il
viendra j'aimerais quand même que nous
créions éclairer sur au fond la personne
à qui on doit s'adresser qui peut être
investies d'une autorité en cas quand
même de circonstances graves et urgents
notamment cas d'hospitalisation
que sido je comprends pas très bien
parce que au fond l'autorité parentale
elle est transférée aux deux parents aux
deux et c'est ce transfert est
indétachable je veux dire aux deux
parents on peut pas la donner à l'un des
deux ou la d2 ne peut pas l'exercer au
détriment de l'autre ou alors l'autre a
donné délégation de signature par
conséquent je contre on comprend pas
très bien ces amendements et
personnellement je ne voterai pas merci
donc je vais mettre ou voir le train de
rectifier bis et le 180 rectifié taire
ceux qui sont favorables eve la main
merci ceux qui sont contre abstentions
ils ne sont pas adoptées le 96 rectifier
ce qui sont pour contre
attention il n'est pas adopté j'en viens
à présent à deux amendements discussion
commune
le 33 actifs y et biz de monsieur gérard
oui monsieur le président il est retiré
naturellement puisqu'ils ne correspond
plus à ce que nous avons adoptées
jusqu'à maintenant très bien merci le
260 rectifier de monsieur retailleau
même chose nous abordons l'amendement
103 présentée par monsieur bah
monsieur le président je vais avant tout
retirer cet amendement mais non sans
vous avoir fourni une explication
depuis quelques années la jurisprudence
est établi et la cour de cassation l'a
confirmé pour permettre dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles et dans
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant à la
compagne de la mère de prendre soin de
l'enfant et cette jurisprudence est né
de situations où on a pu observer que la
mère avait des engagements
professionnels très important et que
c'était en réalité sa compagne qui
s'occupait le plus de l'enfant il faut
naturellement dans ce type de situation
préserver l'autorité parentale du père
qui n'est pas là mais qui exerce cette
autorité parentale conjointement avec la
mer mais il y a le cas où le père est
d'accord et le juge le vérifiera il ya
aussi le cas où la filiation maternelle
n'a pas été établie et dans ce cas il
est souhaitable de permettre
effectivement au tir qui effectivement
s'occupe le plus de l'enfant d'assumer
cette responsabilité dans des conditions
de bonne sécurité juridique il faudrait
d'ailleurs concevoir le la règle
symétrique dans l'hypothèse où c'est le
père qui s'occupe de l'enfant avec son
compagnon et où soit la mère est décédée
soit la filiation maternelle n'est pas
établie ce qui peut arriver tout à fait
exceptionnellement il me semble que
compte tenu de ce qui nous a été
expliqué tout à l'heure sur l'ensemble
des questions qui devraient se rattacher
à la future loi sur la famille il est
préférable de traiter ce dispositif
dans cet ensemble c'est la raison pour
laquelle je retire cet amendement
si monsieur le sénateur il est retiré
j'en viens au 128 rectifié de madame
benbassa
le présente amendement a pour objet
d'élargir la délégation partage de
l'autorité parentale au conjoint ou
ancien conjoint du parent et ce afin
d'offrir des droits au parent non
biologique pour les couples de même sexe
la délégation partage de l'autorité
parentale est la seule possibilité pour
que le parent à l'égard duquel aucune
filiation est établie et quelques droits
et puisse prendre quelques décisions
relatives à l'éducation son enfant mais
en l'état du droit seul et par amp
saisir le juge de cette demande sans
mandement a donc pour objet de permettre
aux conjoints ou à l'ancienne conjointe
de le faire très concrètement ce sont
les situations de séparation des parents
qui sont visés l'ex conjoint pourrait
alors saisir le juge afin de continuer à
exercer l'autorité parentale sur
l'enfant qu'il a voulu et élevé jusque
là et ce même si l'autre parent ne le
souhaite pas donc ce cet amendement je
le retirerais mais c'est une un appel
même la ministre pour qu'elle puisse
prendre en considération cette question
dans sa future loi sur la famille merci
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission
il est retiré très bien il est retiré
bien alors j'en viens à deux amendements
identiques le 182e rectifié terre de
monsieur zocchetto monsieur détraigne
oui cet amendement propose d'instaurer
un système de partage de l'autorité
parentale par convention judiciairement
homologué ce système ferait du partage
de l'autorité parentale pour le beau
parent un dispositif propre et le
rendrait plus souple que le dispositif
existant puisqu'il pourrait être
réalisée par convention homologuée par
le juge aux affaires familiales
l'étendue du partage serait adapteur
roxxor d'exercice unilatérales ou
conjoint de l'autorité parentale en cas
d'exercices conjoints de l'autorité
parentale le beau parent pourrait
réaliser les accuse ul et les actes
graves nécessitant l'accord des deux
parents en cas d'opposition du parent
titulaire de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale mais qui ne vit pas avec
l'enfant le juge aux affaires familiales
pourraient être utilement saisie afin de
trancher le conflit en cas d'exercice
unilatérale de l'autorité parentale le
parent pourrait partager avec le beau
parent le pouvoir de faire tout acte
relatif à la personne de l'enfant dans
le respect des droits de l'autre parent
qui n'exerce pas l'autorité parentale
donc c'est donc un dispositif tout à
fait innovant de partager l'autorité
parentale qui vous est proposée 1269
rectifié de monsieur retailleau c'est le
même donc c'est le même dispositif avec
la même souplesse pour les actes usuels
et je rejoins parfaitement ce que vient
de dire if they tried je pense qu on
apporterait une vraie valeur ajoutée
très concrètement dans la vie pratique
et quotidienne des uns des autres
j'interroge la commission de sur le
rapporteur avis défavorable à
l'amendement est certes intéressant mais
il est largement satisfaits des n'a pas
le droit en vigueur notamment par la
délégation-partage de l'unc et 337 du
code civil et peut-être avant de
modifier
faudrait-il faire un bilan de
l'application depuis 2002 dollar 10 317
du code civil est donc ce bilan sera
fait je pense midam et dans le prochain
projet doit nous aurons un certain
nombre de mesures qui concerneront les
délégation d'autorité parentale en
l'état ça me semble seulement
prématurées et en plus pas très bien
rédigé avis défavorable alors là
carrément défavorable merci à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
effectivement j'utiliserai les mêmes
argumentaires pour dire que ça ne fait
pas partie de cette loi je voudrais dire
à madame benbassa qu'effectivement
toutes les questions qui sont posées et
qu'elle pose devront faire partie de la
réflexion qui sera conduite dans le
cadre de la loi famille comme j'entends
aussi nombre de réflexions sur cette
question de l'autorité parentale et de
la délégation de l'autorité parentale
sur lesquels nous pourrons bien
évidemment travailler ensemble mais ça
ne fait pas partie de cette loi donc
avis défavorable sur les différents
amendements concernant cette question de
la délégation d'autorité parentale
très bien merci je vais mettre aux voix
ces deux amendements identiques ceux qui
sont pour ceux qui sont contre
abstentions
ils ne sont pas adoptées j'en viens à
deux amendements identiques e63 rectifié
terre de monsieur gérard seul président
madame le garde des sceaux le droit
qu'elle prévoit que le juge aux affaires
familiales qui statue sur les modalités
de l'exercice de l'autorité parentale
après séparation des parents peut
décider du vivant même de ses parents
qu'en cas de décès de celui d'entre eux
qui exercent cette autorité
l'enfant n'est pas confiée aux
survivants cet amendement propose de
compléter ce dispositif en permettant
aux tiers qui a résidé avec l'enfant est
l'un de ses parents de saisir
directement le juge aux affaires
familiales d'une demande de se voir
confier l'enfant
il indique également la possibilité de
l'ouverture d'une tutelle en août cet
amendement vise à réformer la procédure
de délégation de l'autorité parentale
prévue par l'article 377 du code civil
la procédure actuelle permet lorsque les
circonstances l'exigent aux pères et
mères de saisir le juge en voir deux des
envois en vue de voir déléguer tout ou
partie de l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale un tiers or elle ne prévoit
pas le cas du décès de l'un des parents
le présent amendement propose de
compléter ce dispositif
en permettant aux tiers qui résidait
avec le parent décédé qui aurait
participé à l'éducation de l'enfant au
quotidien et nous et avec lui des liens
affectifs étroits de saisir le juge en
vue de se voir déléguer tout ou partie
de l'autorité parentale
ces propositions font suite aux
réflexions qui avait été présenté en
2009 dans le cadre de la préparation
d'un avant projet de loi sur l'autorité
parentale et le droit des tiers ainsi
que des pistes émises dans le cadre du
rapport annuel du défenseur des droits
de 2006 droits de l'enfant actuellement
l'enfant au coeur des nouvelles
parentalité pour un statut des tiers qui
partagent ou ont partagé la vie d'un
enfant et ont des liens affectifs forts
avec lui merci le 178 rectifié terre
monsieur détraigne il est défendu avis
de la commission avis défavorable
monsieur le président c'est l'amendement
reprennent deux propositions distinctes
du défenseur des droits qui date de 2006
mais depuis 2006 les choses ont évolué
d'une part des réformes sont intervenus
pour organiser la protection de l'enfant
en cas de défaite ses parents
désignation d'un tuteur d'un mandataire
de protection future
d'autre part fait un sésame cet
amendement remettrait en cause des
équilibres sont lequel notre droite sur
lequel repose le trois civils et le
principe essentiel sur lequel l'autorité
parentale à part appartient aux parents
de l'enfant le parent survivant la
recevant totalement en cas de décès de
l'autre parent notre droit civil
organise alors un mécanisme donc
peut-être faut-il revenir là dessus pas
au détour vers l'amendement en ce moment
ça fera peut être l'objet de
dispositions dans la loi famille et donc
la commission a émis un avis je regarde
un film suivi oui défavorables pour ces
amendements identiques
merci à vis du gouvernement madame le
garde des sceaux monsieur président un
avis défavorable également je vérifiais
je crois que l'article c'est l'article
403 en fait qui permet aux parents qui
dès qui détient seule autorité parentale
de désigner un tuteur
je voulais en avoir le coeur net mais je
vois des approbations donc que
probablement je peux le temps de
retrouver l'art ti
donc c'est un avis défavorable et le
sujet évidemment à sa raison d'être
partiellement en tout cas et il sera
mieux traités dans le projet de loi
famille prochainement merci je vais donc
soumettre ces deux amendements
identiques aux voix 63 rectifie les
terres 178 rectifié taire ceux qui sont
favorables ceux qui sont pour merci ceux
qui sont contre abstention c'est un an
donnant ne sont pas adoptées j'en viens
à deux amendements en discussion commune
le 34 rectifié bis de monsieur g d'are
chez le président mesdames les ministres
cet amendement vise à permettre aux
parents qui exercent l'autorité
parentale sur un enfant mineur de donner
mandat au tiers qui résident avec lui et
l'enfant et à nouer des liens affectifs
étroits avec celui ci de le représenter
en cas de décès ou d'incapacité futur
merci 180 rectifié terre monsieur
détraigne
oui dia il vient d'être présentée par le
doyen gélard c'est le dernier amendement
que nous proposons visant à
l'élaboration d'un statut du beau parent
nous avons noté madame la garde des
sceaux madame la ministre que même si
vous ne donnez pas d'avis favorables ce
soir sur ces amendements
ce sont tout de même des amendements
intéressant qui font progresser la cette
question de la délégation d'autorité
vis-à-vis d'un d'un enfant sans aller
dans certains excès comme d'autres
dispositions qui a été adopté ce soir
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire on a
en attendant les avis dont je crains
qu'on connaisse déjà le sens qu'elle est
donc l'avis de la commission nous le
rapporte lavier défavorable pour la
bonne raison que le dispositif est déjà
satisfait par le droit en vigueur depuis
la réforme de la protection juridique
des majeurs à l'effet en cas
d'incapacité ou de décès et cette
protection peut être aussi mise en cause
dans le cas d'un mandat de protection
future est donc la décision s'impose
alors au juge donc je pense que ces
dispositions sont déjà satisfaites
au surplus elle pourrait faire l'objet
de quelque chose depuis large dans la
future loi famille avis défavorable de
la commission invite du gouvernement
madame lagarde est sous également un
avis défavorable tout en précisant à
monsieur le sénateur détraigne
qu'effectivement le gouvernement est
très attentif à toutes ces propositions
et à toutes ces suggestions
les réponses que nous vous faisons
consiste à dire que les sujets que vous
posez sont de vrais sujets parfois nous
vous disons que c'est satisfait déjà
dans le code civil
parfois nous vous disons que cela mérite
une évaluation d'approfondir la
discussion mais en tout état de cause je
ne doute pas que vous participerez aux
travaux préparatoires à ce projet de loi
famille et que la ministre de la famille
qui a déjà bien bien avancé sur le
projet fera en sorte que tout ce que
vous avez soulevés et qui peut améliorer
les relations entre les enfants et
surtout le maintien de la relation
familiale pour les enfants que tout cela
sera pris sérieusement en considération
merci monsieur sido vous avez la parole
oui écouter et là on s'aperçoit qu'avec
cette loi les les choses deviennent
d'une complication extraordinaire enfin
revenons les pieds sur terre là on a
l'impression d'être dans une bulle
finalement ou non on discute de
problèmes qui éventuellement n'existe
pas je ne sais pas qui a été à l'origine
en amont de ce type d'abonnement j'en
sais rien je ne cherche pas le savoir
d'ailleurs mais ce que je voulais dire
c'est que quand déjà que des parents
biologiques on va le dire comme ça c'est
actuellement comme ça que ça se passe
aujourd'hui transfert l'autorité
parentale à d'autres parents adoptants
le dire comme ça ou éventuellement
simple ou pam enfin l'autorité parentale
c'est déjà compliqué c'est déjà passable
qu'injuste interviennent il faut que les
choses soient faites dans les règles de
l'art si je puis dire
et imaginez un instant qu'on souffre
qu'on sous transfert
cette autorité parentale non enfin
franchement on croit rêver
alors je pense que dans la loi sur la
famille qui viendra madame la ministre y
aura beaucoup de choses à nos 7 3 heures
à famille ça va nous prendre du temps ça
va être compliqué parce qu'il est vrai
que la vie se complique c'est pour ça
peut-être qu'il faudrait pas qu'on fasse
des lois qui permettent qu on complique
à l'envi tout tout ce qui est réellement
déjà compliquée naturellement eh bien on
traitera de cette question mais
actuellement sous traiter cette autorité
parentale me paraît un petit peu
démesuré par rapport à la problématique
actuelle
merci monsieur longuet vous avez la
parole oui monsieur le président madame
le garde des sceaux madame le ministre
mes chers collègues au jeu soutient
naturellement ces deux amendements qui
ont l'immense mérite de montrer le lien
extrêmement étroits entre le principe
que vous avez posé et qui a été adopté
par notre assemblée à l'article 1 et
l'ensemble des dispositions concernant
la famille parce que je ne suis pas le
meilleur juristes de cette assemblée
je connais un petit peu la vie et dans
la vie lorsqu'on ne peut pas se marier
on peut pas se marier
vous ouvrez une porte et en ouvrant
cette porte celle du mariage des
personnes de même sexe vous allez
inévitablement déstabiliser à la fois
les mariages existants et les couples
non mariés homosexuels qui vont être
confrontés à la question simple
allons-nous nous marier ou pas nous
avons de la vie une existe une
connaissance suffisamment riche pour
savoir que tant qu'on ne peut pas se
marier
il est rebelle relativement facile
d'avoir un comportement qui peut changer
lorsque la possibilité du mariage
apparaît non pas pour consolider le
couple retrait pour l'éclaté
car le nombre de situations complexes et
nous les vivons dans nos permanences
quand nous recevons nos administrés qui
ont le don parfois de se mettre dans des
situations à peu près impossible où ils
vivent en concubinage tout en étant
mariée par ailleurs mais et qui sont
incités par l'un ou par l'autre à la
rupture du mariage antérieur lorsque
cette rupture ne débouchaient sur rien
il est évident que cette rupture n'était
pas encourager
si cette rupture débouche sur un mariage
il va donc avoir accélération des
ruptures
donc vous êtes en train de créer par une
sorte de déplacement l'étude de l'insee
sur les couples français cette grande
étude
je crois sur un échantillon de 2 200
mille couples permet d'avoir des vérités
statistiques il y a en effet des enfants
qui vivent dans des couples dans les
faits dans des couples homoparentaux
mais ils ne sont pas les enfants dans
l'immense majorité des dans la quasi
totalité des cas ils ne sont pas conçus
par ces coupes
ils sont simplement les enfants de
couples qui se sont reconstitués sur la
base de l'homosexualité
après avoir vécu une phase
d'hétérosexualité qui leur a permis
d'ailleurs à l'un ou à l'autre d'avoir
un enfant donc ils se partagent cet
enfant tout se passe très bien mais à
partir du moment où il ya possibilité de
mariage
c'est un système de ric hochet
qui va par l'appel au mariage dé
construire d'autres mariages et nous
allons avoir à gérer des relations
extraordinairement complexes entre les
des parents qui étaient mariés mais qui
ne vivait plus ensemble et qui vont être
obligés de divorcer puisqu'ils peuvent
se marier alors voix très honnêtement je
suggère que cette loi sur la famille que
vous nous proposez et bien nous en
adoptant n'attendions l'adoption c'est
le cas de le dire que nous attendions
l'adoption de cette loi pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre la loi sur le mariage
puisque le mariage un double effet il va
sans doute amené des couples légitimes
qui ne vivent plus ensemble et qu'ils
sont hétérosexuels à être confrontés à
la demande de divorce de l'un des deux
qui est la possibilité se marier et nous
allons avoir des concubins homosexuels
qui vont sans doute se disperser parce
que la perspective du mariage va les
effrayer tant qu'ils ne pouvaient pas se
marier ils pouvaient vivre ensemble mais
lorsqu'ils vont être confrontés à
l'obligation de respect de fidélité et
de soutien codifiée par la loi ils vont
sans doute reprendre leur liberté
appréhendant cette situation qu'il
n'avait pas envisagé
je vous suggère madame le garde des
sceaux avec beaucoup de sagesse
d'imaginer de continuer à progresser
dans la voie ouverte et que sur laquelle
ne vous suivront pas mais d'attendre
pour la mettre en oeuvre la loi sur les
familles
très bien merci je mets aux voix je mets
au voile amendement 34 rectifié bis de
monsieur g l'ars qui sont pour
merci ceux qui sont contre abstentions
il n'est pas adopté le 180 rectifier
terre de monsieur zocchetto présentée
par monsieur détraigne ceux qui sont
pour ceux qui sont contre abstentions il
n'est pas adopté l'amendement soixante
dix tombes
j'en viens à l'amendement 35 rectifié
bis présentée par monsieur g d'are
cet amendement a pour objectif est de
faire en sorte que les amendements
portant sur l'autorité partager la
résidence alternée vise essentiellement
à protéger avant tout l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant en lui
garantissant une construction saine
équilibrée
reposant sur deux parents réellement
présents merci à vis de la commission
avis défavorable la solution actuelle
nous apparaît plus sensé que celles
proposées par monsieur gilles a bien
merci à vis du gouvernement est
favorable
merci je vais donc mettre cet amendement
on voit ceux qui sont pour
merci ceux qui sont contre abstentions
il n'est pas adopté j'en viens à cinq
amendements identiques que le 119
rectifié bis de monsieur retailleau
voilà nous sommes conséquent puisque
c'est la déclinaison dans le code de
l'action sociale et des familles de ce
que nous défendons depuis le départ
c'est à dire que le principe qu'un
enfant doit être éduqué et que cette
éducation incombe à ces pères et mères
dans le code de l'action sociale et des
familles
très bien merci madame bruguière merci
monsieur bécaud même chose merci
monsieur revêt ce président j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que on faisait peu de cas
du droit de l'enfant il n'en parlait pas
beaucoup alors nous avons voulu déposer
des amendements qui était peut-être un
peu à répétition on a compris qu'il
n'était pas question qu'il soit adopté
mais on en reparlera c'est vrai comme le
disait ceci d'eau le projet de loi
famille qui interviendra semble-t-il
dans quelques temps et bien devra
reprendre tous ses aspects parce que
l'enfant bien les parents ont des
devoirs par rapport à ses enfants alors
je suis bien que quelques fois il ya
deux des personnes qui préconise
d'enlever l'enfant le plus tôt possible
à l' influence de ses parents pour nous
c'est exactement l'inversé
et dans le domaine des responsabilités
il y à l'éducation et les mieux placés
pour aider à cette éducation
ce sont les parents le père la mère et
quand ils sont séparés aussi a un des
deux qui disparaît c'est le père ou la
mère mais le rôle des parents doit être
essentielle et nous voulions le rappeler
dans cet amendement
merci à vis de la commission la
commission est défavorable pour deux
raisons la première c'est que la matière
et caen et dans le code civil c'est pas
la peine de lescar dans le code de
l'action sociale et que deuxièmement
fait d'amendements dans leur esprit
interdisent en fait l'adoption par des
couples de même sexe
c'est les armements adam et eve on a
longtemps discuté et donc nous sommes
défavorables à tout amendement
merci le gouvernement évidemment
défavorable sans voilà il est 23h30 sur
notre antenne et on poursuit bien
entendu la diffusion de l'examen de ce
projet de loi sur le mariage vous
retrouverez l'émission de serge moati
normalement programmé cette heure là un
petit peu plus tard dans la soirée
quand les sénateurs auront fini
d'examiner les amendements les articles
qu'il reste sur ce texte
on fait un petit point sur la discussion
en rejoignant delphine girard en tribune
de presse delphine oui péril
effectivement à 23h30 et bien il ne
reste plus qu'une quinzaine
d'amendements a examiné les débats
s'accélère on l'a déjà dit alors les
sénateurs vont t'ils et bien poursuivre
cette ligne pour voter aux alentours de
3h ou quatre ans on ne sait pas encore
mais cette éventualité est bien se
précise
on a l'impression que même les sénateurs
ump qui jusqu'à présent avaient
fermement bataillé à chaque amendement
multipliant les prises de parole les
explications de vote et bien sont
beaucoup plus conciliant eux aussi même
s'ils ne lâchent pas prise comme l'avait
indiqué tout à l'heure
l'ancien premier ministre jean-pierre
raffarin ont envie et bien d'arriver aux
explications de vote sur ce projet de
loi voilà perrine à ce qu'on pouvait
dire pour l'instant c'est à vous eh bien
écoutez ans on retourne dans l'hémicycle
on suit toujours la discussion autour de
ce projet de loi et on se retrouve un
petit peu plus tard avec des invités
pour d'autres interventions merci
couples homosexuels ont été conçus par
un père et par une mère que ce couple et
disparaît été dissous juridiquement par
un divorce qu'il n'ait jamais existé ou
qu'il soit maintenu parce que pour des
raisons de convenance
on décide de ne pas trancher en
attendant mieux car l'essentiel de ces
couples de ces homosexuels qui élèvent
des enfants élèves les enfants qui ont
été conçus préalablement dans le cadre
de mme hétérosexualité
quel qu'ait été le statut de cette
hétérosexualité rappeler comme le nous
propose l'auteur de l'amendement que
l'enfant études et et éduqué par son
père et par sa mère n'interdit
absolument pas ultérieurement
un mariage homosexuel mais rappelle que
cet enfant a toujours un impair s'il est
élevé
ensuite par un couple de femmes
homosexuelles et qu'il a toujours une
mer s'il est élevé par un couple de deux
hommes qui se sont constitués
ultérieurement
le lien entre le père et la mère
continue d'exister quel que soit
l'avenir de ce couple d'ailleurs c'est
exactement le problème du divorce et les
divorcés se compose des familles se
recomposent tout le monde se retrouvent
ou se chamaillent que les situations
sont mais il ya toujours un père et une
mère
et il y a toujours un moment où le père
et la mère sont responsables de
l'éducation de l'enfant et son
responsable tout simplement de l'enfant
et cet amendement le rappelle je vois
bien ce qui est proposé on voudrait
gommer ou le père ou la mère
or il existe et dans 95% des cas j'en
suis convaincu à ce jour d'enfant élevé
par des femmes par des couples
homosexuels qui n'ont pas de statut
aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont en aurons un
demain ce sont des enfants de couples
hétérosexuels qui ont éclaté à l'épreuve
du temps parce que l'un des conjoints a
considéré qu'il fallait vivre autrement
c'est son droit mais il n'empêche que le
lien qu'il a créée en faisant un enfant
avec une personne d'un sexe différent
continuer d'exister continuera d'exister
quel que soit l'avenir quelles que
soient les orientations sexuelles
tardive de l'un des deux conjoints
monsieur sido j'ai bien écouté j'ai bien
lu déjà le texte de l'amendement proposé
des quatre amendements identiques
j'ai bien écouté mon collègue et ami
gérard longuet écoutez comme je lis bien
le texte qui est proposé c'est ça
d'ailleurs le danger tous ses
amendements qui arrivent par le biais
d'associations etc pour les signent
ensemble mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
mariage pour tous cette affaire-là tels
que je lui le texte
l'éducation des enfants incombe au père
et à la mère bon c'est tout franchement
il n'y a rien d'extraordinaire à cela et
dire que quand la filiation est établie
pour l'un l'autre ne s'en occupe pas
enfin enfin si l'autre s'en occupe pas
c'est soit pas le père soit pas la mer
enfin si c'est le père et la mère
naturellement bien évidemment les deux
doivent s'occuper de l'éducation de
l'enfant ça n'a rien à voir donc c'est
un amendement cavaliers qui avait
absolument rien à voir avec cette fois
que nous discutons +4 5 jours
aujourd'hui et par conséquent je suis
très dubitatif sur la pertinence de ces
amendements si monsieur béchu merci
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux madame la ministre monsieur
le rapporteur madame la rapporteure
monsieur le président de la commission
ce sont les propos de la ministre de la
famille qui m'amène à réagir
vous nous dites madame la ministre
avoir un père et une mère ça n'est pas
la garantie d bien élevé regarder vipère
au poing
c'est le mot garantis que vous avez
utilisé mais je veux bien que ce soit le
mot assurances en faisant référence à
hervé bazin il faut juste rappeler une
chose personne ici dans cet hémicycle
n'a soutenu le contraire
personne n'a dit qu'il y avait en
quelque sorte une garantie de bonne
éducation qui s'attachait ou une
assurance de bonne éducation qui
s'attachait un type de famille
simplement madame la ministre
à travers vos propos je n'aimerais pas
qu'on finisse par croire que le fait de
ne pas être élevé par un père et une
mère deviendrait ou une garantie ou une
assurance d'être bien élevé et pour
aller plus loin parce que dans ce débat
malgré leur qui passe il faut aussi dire
les choses
nous avons la conviction et la certitude
que ça reste à défaut d'une gare entier
d'une assurance le meilleur modèle
possible et souhaitable pour un enfant
merci je vais donc mettre au voir les
deux trois quatre amendements ceux qui
sont pour merci ceux qui sont contre
abstentions ces amendements ne sont pas
adoptées j'en viens à l'amendement 56
rectifié bis de monsieur gérard s'agit
là monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres de combler une lacune du fait
de l'inexistence des ces données dans
l'étude d'impact
en effet nous allons demander dans cette
affaire un rapport au gouvernement sur
les conséquences en matière d'adoption
internationale de l'application de la
présente loi et en particulier sur le
nombre d'enfants proposés à l'adoption
en france
cette information est nécessaire tant
pour les couples hétérosexuels que
naturellement pour les nouveaux couples
autorisés par la présente loi sur le
rapporteur défavorable d'autant plus que
l'agent français pour l'adoption est le
consensus était à des adoptions
fournissent des rapports annuels qui
donne un certain nombre de données et
qui permettent le contrôle du parlement
merci madame la ministre
à vis des savoirs pour la même raison
sachant qu'en plus le sénat lui-même qui
généralement dispose d'une capacité de
rapports de missions de rapports de
grande qualité parce que c'est souvent
le cas le sénat peut lui-même procédé à
ce rapport sans que le gouvernement vous
le fournissent nécessairement donc avis
défavorable si la parole à monsieur sido
là monsieur le rapporteur pardonnez moi
je suis pas d'accord avec vous il s'agit
bel et bien d'une étude d'impact j'ai
compris monsieur gélard de cette loi sur
l'adoption internationale
alors même que l' agence nationale jean
ce pour l'adoption internationale à
laquelle je participe et je sais je vous
conseil d'administration d'ailleurs
donne des chiffres avant etc santé
autrement dit et par conséquent
effectivement je pense qu'il faut un
rapport sur cette affaire là mais on
connaît parce que je les dis et redis je
veux le redire une dernière fois les
conséquences de cette loi pour
l'adoption par tous ou par les
homosexuel le mariage mariage et donc
l'adoption
on en connaît les conséquences déjà que
les pays qui offrait des enfants
l'adoption internationale était réticent
quand il s'agissait de personnes seules
ce que permettait la loi
déjà c'est évident c'est du vécu ce bon
et bien à partir du moment où la france
va adopter cette loi il est clair
l'afrique du sud l'a dit mais le vietnam
le fera la colombie se ferme etc etc
il est clair qu'il n'y aura plus la
russie au ces il n'y aura plus
d'adoption internationale par conséquent
on connaît déjà
monsieur le doyen mais il serait mieux
que ce soit confirmée par un rapport
on connaît déjà le résultat de cette loi
sur l'adoption internationale
je trouve que c'est un excellent
amendement qui fera une étude que une
étude d'impact etc ce poste merci je
vais mettre aux voix cet amendement 56
rectifié bis qui sont pour ceux qui sont
contre ceux qui s'abstiennent
l'amendement n'est pas adopté j'en
arrive à l'amendement 50 de rectifier
biz présenté par le sujet d'art oui
c'est un amendement qui avait déposé
notre collègue frogier et qui souhaite
que à l'instar de ce qui fut fait pour
la nouvelle calédonie brou alice et
futuna on puisse se compléter les
dispositions manquantes
en ce qui concerne le pacs en nouvelles
en polynésie française où il n'existe
pas à l'heure actuelle de trop
d'enregistrement du pacs au greffe du
tribunal de papeete
merci monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
invitée favorable je vous dis a expliqué
tout à l'heure le pack n'est pas
appliquée en polynésie car le pacte
l'application est de la compétence de
l'assemblée territoriale et donc ce
n'est pas à nous de dire à la famille
territoriale de polynésie
vous devrez piqué le pacs par contre par
contre le mariage du est applicables de
plein droit
merci madame la garde des sceaux oui
mais même avis monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur parce que le pacte
civil de solidarité est un contrat et
les compétences du territoire de
polynésie les contrats font partie des
compétences du territoire de polynésie
par conséquent c'est au territoire de
prendre la décision de d'instaurer un
pacs j'ai déjà proposé aux députés de
polynésie qui ont soulevé le même
problème une séance de travail
d'ailleurs il y en a une qui a dû avoir
lieu pour les aider éventuellement à
rassembler les matériaux commencé à
rédiger je veux le dire en toute
modestie commencé à rédiger
éventuellement contrat civil de
solidarité par contre le mariage ça
n'est pas un contrat rencontre entre
deux personnes mais c'est surtout une
institution c'est l'état des personnes
donc cela s'applique ce n'est pas la
compétence territoriale et cela
s'appliquera donc en polynésie qui fait
partie des territoires de lag
je vais aux voix le 52e rectifié bis
ceux qui sont pour ceux qui sont contre
ap station il n'est pas adopté j'en
viens à deux amendements en discussion
commune le 235 rectifié de monsieur
darniche si monsieur le président madame
administrés chers collègues
il s'agit de demander au gouvernement
par rapport annuel d'établir un état des
lieux de l'application de la théorie du
genre en france
il n'est pas question par cet amendement
de remettre en cause cette théorie qui
met en lumière par des méthodes
scientifiques les modes d'organisation
de la société à partir des fonctions
spécifiques assignés à l'homme et à la
femme en raison de leur différence de
leurs différences sexuelles et des
situations d'inégalité qui en résulte il
est en effet intéressant de s'interroger
à travers l'histoire sur les différences
non biologique entre hommes et femmes
en cherchant la racine et les causes des
inégalités observé en revanche il nous
faut être renseigné sur l'importance de
l'introduction de la théorie du genre en
france car cette théorie qui n'est pas
une étude scientifique mais un système
de pensée pourrait avoir inspiré ou
pourrait inspirer notre législation
or pour les tenants de cette théorie ce
n'est pas la différence des sexes qui
importe mais la perception subjective
que chaque individu se fait de son
identité lui permettant ainsi de
déterminer librement son orientation
sexuelle qui pourrait prendre des formes
diverses
tout comme aide pour évoluer dans le
temps la théorie du genre en se fondant
plus sur la différence des sexes mais
sur celle des sexualités se retourne en
fait contre les femmes car il ne peut y
avoir égalité sans reconnaissance des
sexes
l'homme et la femme ont une spécificité
liée à la nature et la véritable égalité
consiste à en tenir compte
c'était un différenciation des sexes
conduit donc à une rupture majeure de
notre société et un bouleversement pour
l'ensemble des français
ceux ci ont le droit de savoir la
théorie du genre ne peut être imposée en
catimini sans que les citoyens des
conscience de ce qu'elle représente et
des conséquences qu'elle entraîne tant
au niveau de la politique de la petite
enfance de l'éducation de l'enseignement
scolaire et supérieur des droits des
femmes du droit de la famille du droit
social de la justice et de
l'administration
il nous faut donc un état des lieux et
c'est l'objectif de cet amendement
merci le 272 rectifiée suit retailleau
oui rapidement jeu
c'est un amendement qui propose la même
chose que ce que philippe darniche mon
ami vient de vient de proposer
simplement je voudrais signaler c'est
d'ailleurs parce ce gouvernement qui l'a
mis à l'étude dans les programmes n'ont
pas de philosophie mais de svt de
science la théorie du gender et proposer
maintenant à l'enseignement je voudrais
indiquer que celle qu'il a pensé conçu
judith butler avait écrit un livre
trouble dans le genre pour un féminisme
de la subversion demandé un rapport
c'est tout simplement savoir si nos
enfants sont soumises à une subversion
et à kehl subversion je vous rappelle
que cette théorie pousse à une
déconstruction reconstruction en matière
de genre c'est évident en matière de
famille qui devient suspecte puisque la
famille serait maintenu dans un état de
domination soumettant aussi les enfants
un déterminisme nature est négatif
maternité suspect aussi puisque l'idée
de la seule reproduction naturelle doit
être déconstruites au profit de l'idée
selon laquelle l'enfant ne se reçoit pas
mais il ce désir voilà il faut donc
recourir à d'autres techniques
bon je trouve qu'à partir du moment où
cette théorie est une théorie et qu'elle
fait l'objet d'enseignement jeu nous
pensons aussi d'ailleurs que sans doute
n'est-elle pas complètement étrangère à
l'inspiration de ce texte je pense en
tout cas que le gouvernement serait bien
inspiré de proposer à la représentation
nationale un rapport sur les
conséquences de cette théorie en tout
cas de son enseignement merci monsieur
le rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cette défavorable car la
théorie du genre n'a pas de rapport
direct avec le texte donc défavorable à
la production des thés rapport madame la
madame la ministre
l'avis du gouvernement sur ces
amendements les mêmes arima cher
président merci je vais donc consulté le
sénat sur ces deux amendements 235
gratifié non sur le 235 rectifié de
monsieur dernier ceux qui sont pour ceux
qui sont contre abstentions il n'est pas
adoptée même vote pour le suivant
très bien je suis maintenant saisi
d'amendements sur l'intitulé du projet
de loi
cinq amendements en discussion commune
les deux premiers 57 rectifié bis et 140
rectifié tombe le lamarre demande 264
rectifié de monsieur retailleau je vais
soutenir les deux si vous me autorisé
monsieur le président ce sont des
amendements un peu facétieux simplement
nous je souhaitais que avec d'autres
collègues mais important dire les choses
nommer les choses notamment donc en
indiquant qu'il s'agissait d'un texte
qui visait aussi à supprimer la
différence de la différence sexuelle
propre à la filiation père c'est l'avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
la commission est défavorable car les
amendements ne sont pas seulement
facétieux mais un peu provocateur quand
même merci la vie du gouvernement madame
la ministre
le même avis en supposant que madame la
sénatrice des esgaulx apprécié puisque
madame c'est la sénatrice ne goûte guère
que landes et en un peu l'atmosphère
mais donc là lorsque lorsque le génie
vient de vos rangs j'espère que vous y
êtes sensibles madame la sénatrice
merci monsieur béchu vous intervenir
vous avez la parole non je juste juste
pour dire qu' il ya un amendement qui
facétieux soit mais il ya le deuxième
sur lequel je ne comprendrais pas qu'il
ya un avis défavorable puisque ça
correspond très précisément à ce sur
quoi vous nous avez fait voter le
dernier amendement que nous examinons ce
soir après c'est fini il dit quoi
il dit que ce n'est pas le mariage pour
tous que c'est le mariage et l'adoption
aux couples de même sexe ou pour
reprendre vos mots le mariage et
l'adoption pour tous pourquoi refuser de
modifier l'intitulé du projet de loi qui
intègre l'adoption comme un droit
nouveau
et comme une égalité
nouvelle alors qu'on pourrait penser que
c'est avec fierté que vous avez porté et
défendu ce texte et l'ensemble de ses
conséquences
donc je ne comprends pas que le
rapporteur et plus encore le
gouvernement refuse d'ajouter le mot
adoption dans le titre du projet qu'il
défend et ça aurait le mérite de
clarifier encore un peu plus la réalité
du changement juridique que vous nous
proposez
doit-on voir madame la ministre
et ce sera pas une facétie de ma part de
le dire comme ça doit-on voir dans ce
refus de m l'adoption dans le titre du
projet de loi le fait que vous savez que
nos concitoyens n'ont pas le même degré
d'adhésion au mariage et à l'adoption et
qu'ils sont largement majoritaires
contre l'adoption élargie à tous les
couples dans ce pays
c'est la question que je me pose mais je
ne veux pas croire que ce soit la seule
raison pour laquelle vous refusé de
nommer les choses telles qu'elles sont
merci alors monsieur le rapport tamada
leurs ministres ensuite cher christophe
déçu du revient que vous voulez avoir la
parole le dernier mais vous l'êtes pas
mis en accusation
vous l'êtes pas l'accusé vous ne vous
défendez de rien donc pourquoi
sommes-nous compte cet amendement parce
que ce n'est pas l'adoption aux couples
de même sexe mais aux personnes de même
sexe donc c'est mal rédigé c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes
défavorables
merci madame la ministre
monsieur le président le gouvernement y
est défavorable pour d'autres raisons
monsieur le sénateur béchu sénateur
biechel la démonstration que vous venez
de faire vous l'avez déjà fait
et méfiez vous de ne pas avoir le
vertige à force de tourner comme ça
autour de la des mêmes arguments
monsieur le sénateur nous avons dit à
plusieurs reprises ici dans cet
hémicycle que le mariage que le mariage
emporte l'adoption vous êtes sénateur
vous êtes législateur vous le savez le
gouvernement a eu justement du courage
du courage en disant parlons
systématiquement de mariage et
d'adoption
parce que le citoyen lui n'est pas censé
savoir que le mariage emporte l'adoption
donc nous avons systématiquement dit
vous prétendez que nous avons nous
sommes nous nous avancions à à visage
masqué la masquer non justement
nous n'avons cessé peu de parler de
mariage et d'adoption
parce que nous estimions que le citoyen
qui ne lit pas le code civil tous les
matins contrairement à certains
sénateurs et que ceux-ci doëlan n'est
pas censé savoir que le mariage emporte
l'adoption mais vous savez que par
l'article 343 le mariage emporte
l'adoption donc lorsque nous faisons du
droit lorsque nous sommes entre
législateurs il n'y a pas lieu de dire
le mariage et l'adoption
pendant toute la période d'explications
nous avons dit ouverture du mariage et
de l'adoption aux couples de même sexe
voilà mais c'est notre code civil qui
fait que le mariage on porte l'adoption
il n'y a donc pas nécessité à le
préciser que longueuil la parole madame
le garde des sceaux juridiquement votre
démonstration est incontestable mais je
soutiens totalement la maman qui était
présenté et admirablement défendu par
christophe béchu pour une raison très
simple c'est qu en autorisant le mariage
des personnes de même sexe vous les
condamnez à l'adoption
aujourd'hui 95% des enfants de couples
homosexuels sont issus de mariages
ou de couples hétérosexuels constituée
sous différentes formes en leur offrant
la possibilité du mariage vous les
condamnez au mariage c'est à dire vous
les comptes au mariage homosexuel c'est
à dire vous les condamnez à l'adoption
vous aviez raison de le rappeler si
monsieur le noir c'est le président
mesdames les mini vga collègues je
voudrais abondé dans le sens qui vient
d'être indiqué par mon ami gérard
longuet au terme de cette discussion et
avant que nous nous retrouvions demain
pour les explications de vote vrai dire
mes amis me disent que vous avez au
cours des jours que nous avons passées
ensemble décrit un monde a pu mon
merveilleux
un monde dans lequel chacun oui oui oui
chacun de ceux qui étaient des visées
par ce texte allait vivre un grand
bonheur et qui était promis une belle
destinée or il est dans quelques
secondes minuit cendrillon va se
retrouver avec la citrouille au lieu son
carrosse ses souliers de boire au lieu
de ses souliers de verre et la réalité
va s'imposer
beaucoup plus dures que celles que vous
avez indiquée et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il voudrait dire que vous avez
construit un édifice sur lequel le rêve
a été décrit mais où les réalités vont
s'imposer
sénateur je mets aux voix ces deux
amendements jeu mais au moins on voit
l'amendement 264 rectifier ce qui sont
pour ceux qui sont contre abstentions il
n'est pas adopté 263 rectifier ce qui
sont pour contre abstentions il n'est
pas adopté mes chers collègues
oui nous avons terminé l'examen des
article du projet de loi et des
amendements portant article additionnel
je veux vous remercier d'avoir tous
participé à ce débat demain matin nous
procéderons aux explications de vote et
au vote sur le projet de loi
je demande s'ils le veulent bien au
groupe de me transmettre la liste des
intervenants dans ses explications sur
le projet de loi le
l'ordre du jour dans du vendredi 12
avril 2013 à 9 heures
explications de vote et vote sur le
projet de loi ouvrant le mariage aux
couples de personnes de même sexe la
séance est levée
et voilà le sénat on a fini avec
l'examen de tous les articles et tous
les amendements déposés sur ce projet de
loi
près de huit jours après le début de
l'examen de ce texte on retrouve pour un
dernier point dans l'hémicycle delphine
en tribune de presse des fuyards
oui perrine alors on l'a vu à la droite
est bien dans un dernier baroud
d'honneur avait proposé des amendements
jugé par l'auteur même de ces
amendements bruno retailleau facétieux
puisqu'il s'agissait de modifier à
l'intitulé du projet de loi
et de rajouter bien projet de loi
ouvrant le mariage et l'adoption aux
couples de même sexe actuellement le
mois adoption ne figurent pas dans ce
projet doit en tous les cas et bien ce
soir on a vu que les débats s'étaient
considérablement accéléré et il faudra
donc attendre demain matin 9h pour
écouter les explications de vote de
l'ensemble des groupes politiques du
sénat sur ce projet de loi
en tous les cas merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve pelling bien
entendu demain en direct à partir de 9
heures exactement delphine rendez vous
demain matin à 9h sur notre antenne pour
suivre les explications de vote
et puis le vote final sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi mariage pour tous merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi très bonne
soirée à tous sur l'antenne de la chaîne
parlementaire tout de suite vous
retrouvez sage mathy pour justement une
émission consacrée au mariage pour tous
très bons rails